[Music]
sketch that I really like it's about a
basketball player and it's his postgame
rant yes when he's he's so exuberant and
tell us first of all who this is based
on so this okay this isn't the first
episode of the season two based on Kevin
Garnett you remember like when the
Celtics won a couple years Wayne yeah he
went a little bit crazy that at the end
of the game he was just so passionate
and he was and he gets so do some so
amped up right now so fired up and he
was like you know anything is possible
anything is possible and you know so we
we sort of figured like you know you are
you know a 611 black man mr. Garnett yes
you can win the NBA championship but you
know IRA Goldstein in Upper West Side he
can't do that
so that we took that hyperbole to the
next level and to the next step let's
take this this is a really funny clip
from the the show it's called you can
fly sassy Charlie Sanders fresh off of
his uh victory and just feel like he's
ready to touch the moon [ __ ] floor
you believe in yourself the way I
believe in myself tonight you will fly
what's next for Charlie Sanders and
their own hands you can actually fly
not literally yes your honor you can
jump kids I want you to go up on your
roofs right now
subsequently looked up to Torrance
literally and metaphorically found that
whereas I was not incorrect they did not
mean what I thought they invent for some
reason just like Steve Urkel when they
don't know why